foreign
Houston Texas hi Tara how are you
hi I'm doing well how are you Dave
better than I deserve what's up
okay so I have been uh working the
program for a while I'm on baby step two
so I'm still paying off some debt
um I am almost 39 years old I've never
had a 401k and the company that I work
for just approached me with that they do
match a hundred percent up to three
percent and then up to six percent they
match uh 50 so my question is I still
have about forty thousand dollars
um in debt to pay but I wasn't sure if I
should go ahead and start putting in the
401K since I'm so far like I've never so
far behind so I feel like I'm going to
be playing catch-up and uh since I don't
have anything starting from zero
um so but I don't know if I should take
that money and you start putting it in
now or wait until
my 40 000 is completely paid off so we
get people who call in all the time and
they have done what you want to do
they've just went ahead and started
investing not built their savings not
paid off their debt and then an
emergency comes and suddenly they're
401K becomes their emergency fund that's
thing number one so I'm just going to
give you a couple of thoughts to just
let them sink in on why this is not a
good idea and honestly if you're
following our plan the way we teach is
you pause if you currently investing you
pause take that money in your case you
weren't already so you've got all of
your income at your disposal to pay off
this debt you've got 40K left keep
moving through this and then when the
time comes you're going to be able to
take advantage of that
um how much have you paid off already
I've paid off around probably almost six
thousand dollars six and I could have I
could have six thousand and I could have
done more I haven't I haven't been how
long has that have you been working on
that
about four months
and what do you make
I make my salary is 95
000 a year and I get about twenty
thousand twenty to thirty thousand
dollars in bonuses okay where's all your
money going to
foreign
I went through a divorce and I had one
car payment and I ended up giving it to
my daughter who was 16 and bought myself
a new car oh and that's how I got in the
Trap of two car payments so you have
forty thousand dollars in debt and how
much of the 40-ish cars
38.
and and what do you owe on your car
28 on mine and 10 on hers
elf and she's 16.
she's 18 now 18. is she working
she is okay
um all right
um
so
the plan that we teach don't start
investing until you're out of debt
assumes that you're going to lean in and
get out of debt with great focused
intensity that you don't have
right you're playing footsie with this
idea you haven't leaned in and said I'm
selling everything in sight I'm getting
out of debt I'm sick and tired of being
broke I make 90 000 a year I got nothing
I'm 39 I'm scared I'm gonna go get me
some and I'm gonna get my debt cleaned
up yesterday I'm not going out to eat
I'm not going on vacation and please
don't talk to me about a new purse you
are getting out of debt and you you're
not at that level
you're just kind of you're just kind of
intellectually exploring this you've not
emotionally engaged it is that fair
it is yeah so that's what that's why
this seems that's why this seems
appealing to you go and jump into the
401K because it feels like you're going
to be in debt forever and it feels like
that because you're going to be in debt
forever
right unless you change
so you can do whatever you want to do
obviously you're a grown-up lady you've
got a great intellect you can do a lot
of things you can go be normal and start
the 401K while you try to limp out of
this debt and keep making these same
mistakes or if you're going to work our
plan which is you called us so that was
your mistake
because we we love you and we are we are
going to tell you the truth and so
that's right and you're tripping right
now yeah so uh you know
18 year old is going to save up three
thousand dollars in the next couple
months and buy a car and we're gonna
sell her car you're going to sell your
car
and we're going to get you out of debt
in a few months probably by Christmas
you're gonna be driving a couple of five
thousand dollar cars and you'll be debt
free build your emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses then save up
and get you a little better car and um
you're 100 debt free but the house at
this point and then you can start
putting by this time next year easily
you'll be putting 15 of your income away
for retirement and if you put fifteen
percent of ninety thousand dollars away
from age 41 to age 65 you will have
several million dollars really if you
keep doing what you're doing now you're
gonna have nothing
except rusted cars with payments on them
we had a girl in my Financial Peace
University class which by the way if you
haven't taken that you need to get
signed up for that she was your age she
had about uh 19 000 left to pay off she
was so worried that she was not going to
have anything in retirement because she
had not started investing right then and
there we walked through the financial
roadmap plan and we walked through we
were able to show her that by the time
she pays off her debt if she just puts
the 15 away she was going to retire with
two million dollars you'll be a bit more
than that and you'll yeah you'll be out
more because I remember where her income
was but yeah you start saving 15 of 100
Grand and you do that for over uh 25
years that's about three million bucks I
mean and that's if you don't get a raise
and you're gonna get raised you've got
time sure you've got time but you don't
have time to keep doing what you've been
doing
because if you keep doing the same thing
over and over again and expecting a
different result
which is embracing car payments because
car payments are a way of life and I
have to have a good car because I'm a
divorcee and I'm scared to death the car
is going to break and I have to have a
good car for my kid because I'm scared
of death my female daughter my daughter
obviously she's female is going to uh
have a breakdown I'm scared and I'm
scared and I'm scared and I'm scared and
I'm scared and so I'm paying car
payments on forty thousand dollars worth
of cars well I make 90 and I'm broke
that's what that fear is doing to you
and so and by the way I'm not asking you
and the 18 year old to drive three to
five thousand dollar cars for the rest
of your life I'm asking you for you to
drive them for a chapter in your life so
that you never have to drive them again
I can assure you I did not drive a five
thousand dollar car over here today
quite the contrary I drive whatever I
want these days but I paid a price for
the last 35 years
by staying out of debt and only buying
things I could afford and then I've got
the money I hear that
that's the way it works so yeah live
like no one else so later you can live
like no one else you're a sharp lady
Tara I appreciate you calling in thank
you for joining us and and uh apologize
for picking on you but just know we it's
because we love you and we want you to
win and um but because
Jade there's something and we just got a
minute for the break but it's very smart
to say this
there you cannot sort of do things that
require you to transform your life if
you want to create transformation
you have to push yourself over to the
edge of extreme
yeah yeah you have to do really whacked
out weird things and then when it swing
when once you've reset your your life
you reset the grooves in your brain your
habit patterns your spiritual beliefs
once you've reset those things by doing
the extreme then you can do something
less extreme much less extreme and still
stay on track but you know you in other
words
if you're gonna if you're 350 400 pounds
and you want to lose weight you have to
shock your system by doing extreme
things yeah you throw out all the
cupcakes you throw out all the crap in
the cabinet a period of time you can't
touch anything that looks like that that
or that for a period of time you got to
go over there now later on if you're 180
pounds you know you can have a cupcake
but I'm not suggesting debt at that
point I still don't I still don't do
that right but I mean my point is you
can breathe a little bit be a little bit
but more normal but I'm suggesting Tara
that we push you over to the extreme and
you do weird uncomfortable things for a
bit to get your get yourself on track
permanently manage your habits yeah
that's good